in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Kara
and Christopher are with us hey guys how
are you good how are you better than I
deserve welcome where you guys from
Cincinnati Ohio
fine welcome to Nashville thank you and
you're here to do a debt-free scream we
are I love it and how much have you paid
off a little over 85,000 excellent how
long did that take about 17 months way
to go and your range of income during
that time we started at about 90 and we
finished about 150 - that's a little
jump in 17 months what happened to your
income oh wow we started the journey um
unexpectedly going from two incomes down
to one oh and that was kind of the kick
in the pants to get us on the right
track so then the job came back and so
the income goes back up okay yeah that's
how you get a $70,000 raise and a 17
months all right good so what do you
guys do for a living so I'm a fundraiser
for a large public school district cool
and uh what do you do Christopher I work
in market research okay and so who went
who hit the who didn't have the job when
this thing started uh I'm the one who
got the involuntary stay at home dads
that is for a short time involuntary
stay-at-home dad status that's a long
title day I love it
so you guys are kicking it though
congratulations so that woke you up
that's it
and then what did you do we got
intentional I think it was a wake-up
call that we weren't living intentional
and we made too much money to be that
broke and it was devastating we weren't
prepared for it and we couldn't make it
snap out of you know yeah and we have a
four year old and it was just we didn't
want her living like that or growing up
like that and so we got on a budget and
we learned to live on one income and he
went back to work shortly after we
started the journey and all of his
paychecks went to pay off the debt so we
do it in 17 months right yeah Wow that's
very cool and so how did you come across
us how are we taught into this yeah so I
read the Total Money Makeover over
Christmas break and shared it with him
and he got on board and then we took an
FPU class through
Church and ended up helping facilitate a
class after that Oh later now
coordinators from Santa Peace University
your big time yeah way to go thank you
for leading the class we appreciate that
it's really rewarding to watch other
people do the same thing you see that
get to watch them turn around like you
did yeah yeah it was great to be able to
share our story and we were still and
baby step two at the time and it was
just nice to be able to support others
and that way very cool which church are
you in Cincinnati crossroads oh yeah
great Church okay very cool very well
done eighty-five thousand and seventeen
months that's kicking it I mean that's
serious you guys changed a bunch of
stuff in your life didn't you we did we
did which the budget was key we just we
weren't living on a budget and then it
just it clicked it made sense and it was
really empowering I think it it helped
us turn around what was a hopeless
situation into a hopeful situation going
through FPU and reading the book gave us
hope when we didn't have it before then
and so we're in a position now that if
that ever happens again we're prepared
for oh yeah changes everything
yeah so Christopher how tough was this
for you you lose your job you come home
and you guys are looking at these bit
stack of bills and you're going wow this
is scary how long have you been married
at that point 12 years yeah yeah so okay
we've been through you know you know ups
and downs just normal life things yeah
you know you know what happens with us
as normally is we really circle the
wagons and you know lay out right these
are the problems this is how we're going
to fix it and we just do it done of a
thing so it was a it was about time for
refocusing if you will and so you know
when I did lose my job we had a little
bit of time before and you know
severance went out and whatnot so we
kind of looked at alright what's coming
in what's going out and what are we
going to do about this and
you know we we didn't pout about it we
didn't cry about it it was just this is
how we're going to attack it and you
know luckily Kara came across your plan
and we sat down and we're like alright
wait so we have to take out all of this
out of the savings and pay off these
debts and I'm not working all right
let's do it
okay it was just kind of a leap of faith
it was it is one of those things where
if you don't just if you don't give it a
hundred percent you're not going to get
on percent amount so you know once
you're committed to it you just do it
and I can't imagine going
I can't imagine eating lunch out at work
anymore because I haven't for so long it
is one of those things where it's like
you know that $5 mil here $10 mil there
is nowhere near worth as much as six
months and you know the emergency fund
and yeah you know the 529 and the
important things you had a collar on
earlier this this week and he talked
about no longer paying for your past but
you know working towards your future and
it was to me that just encompass
everything that you know we've kind of
come back to focus on yeah when you're
writing debt checks you're looking back
all the time and when you're you know
when you're saving and investing you're
looking for and giving you're looking
forward you know that's very well said
good very good
there was yeah there was I mean there
was shame there at least for me most of
the debt was my graduate student loan
and I just kept thinking we would be in
a much better spot if we didn't have
this payment every month but going
through the process turned what was
shameful into something that was really
empowering and really proud of how far
we've come
yeah you already drive your heroes man
you killed it
I'm so proud of you very very well done
so how much was in savings that you
pulled towards the 85 about 12,000 okay
yeah that and at the time he's sitting
there without a job that's that it's not
a it's not a leap of faith but man it
just really required some gut check yeah
that's big yeah I think we sat on it for
about 30 days and yeah and talked about
it and prayed about it and you know it
was we just took a step in faith and
said this is this is a plan we need to
be honest what we need to be doing and
this will work we got to do it but it
sure is scary
yeah yeah it's even scarier yeah you
know that's good but that you know
there's something about that that drives
the whole process in a positive way
right it really is I'm in I'm freaking
all in yeah that's it
so very cool well congratulations you
two very well done so now you're leading
a class and there's a guy walks into the
class and goes I got laid off today and
what are you telling mostly that it's
not as bad as what it seems at this
minute right you got to kind of step
back and what do you have where's your
support and what are your goals kind of
a thing right and after you have that
kind of teeny tiny pity party um you
just they put straps on boots for a
reason and you know I couldn't even tell
you how many applications and how many
calls and and whatnot but that's what
she's got to do you just got a refocus
and your main job now is to you know cut
your money going out and increase that
money coming in and you just gotta do
what you gotta do and there's hope and
there's hope
yeah I mean I guess I gotta do steps for
a reason who is just put one foot in
front of the other and everyday you make
a little bit of progress in yeah you
know what it started out seeming
insurmountable has come and gone in 17
months and now we're on to the next step
so it can be done in with the the
support part of it is like if that
person was by themselves that'd be super
tough but if you if you got a good
partner in crime if you will
Danny uh there's really not much you
can't accomplish yeah agree I agree
you guys are neat you're fun you're
going to be your great coordinators and
your great your great heroes thank you
thank you for hanging out with us and
telling your story it's very well done
so on to the next step which is building
wealth and changing your family tree
completely Chris Hogan's retire inspired
book will help with that we're going to
give you a copy of it so that we can
participate in the next part yeah of
your journey not to be in the first part
will be in the next part as well and
completely change everything now it's
going to be amazing as young as you are
as smart as you are as as good of
careers as you've got you're going to
you're going to do so well it's going to
be amazing I mean when you're 65 years
old where you're going to be sitting is
going to blow your mind
where you could be if you
justkeep generally on the track that
you're on very well done so we'll
definitely give you a copy of that and
so here Keira and Christopher Cincinnati
Ohio $85,000 paid off in 17 months count
it down let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one we're free well done you
two very very very well done oh man that
is awesome very well done
excellent job hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show so you have to break
the cycle you have to flip this thing on
its head and make it behave you've got
to get so fired up and wired up that
you're broke friends think you've lost
your mind
[Music]
Oh
[Music]